it could take years to repair the damage
caused by these floods
days of heavy rain have better parts of
new zealand south island
some areas in the city of nelson are
unrecognizable
on the ground the destruction is
extensive
roads are blocked and officials have
closed schools
entire communities have been forced out
of their homes with some declared unsafe
or simply uninhabitable
the
basically just collapsed and then we saw
the dirt rolling straight to our
property so we just yeah left the
property at about 8 15 um straight to a
motel and i came this morning to assess
the situation it's pretty bad
city officials warn there's no timeline
for when people will be allowed to go
back home
we will be taking a prudent approach and
i'll make no excuse for that i would
rather we protect
the property and lives of people as
opposed to allowing people back and i
cannot unfortunately guarantee that
people will be in the houses again today
nearby towns have also registered record
levels of rain
what we experienced this week was
probably the most intense increase in
water flow in a river
in a catchment that we've seen
for 100 years
more rainfall is expected along with
warnings of more damage
katie lopez
al jazeera